all right we've got a little something
special this week on hatred mail in
order to be timely
this week's hatred mail introduction
refers to Cobb Steffi but I don't know
which is a funnier pronunciation of Cobb
Becky so we've got two hatred mail
intros this week here's the first one
listen to the pronunciation then we'll
compare to option number two Patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because they
pay
okay that's cup space pay that's option
number one now here's option number two
for for that amazing word tell me which
one you like better Patriot mail written
by Patriots who hate David Pakman
because America and because Kofi P so
kabhi speak of FA I kind of like Cobb
Steffi yes is sort of a hybrid of the
two
I wonder if because Donald Trump
invented the word that he gets to decide
the pronunciation probably yeah that's
probably true anyway alright let's let
me know which one you like better and we
can add it to the regular rotation of
Patriot male introductions here is this
week's Patriot mail episode for you
David Pakman you are an idiot David
Pakman is a lying Democrat he's also HIV
positive the quintessential degraded low
IQ loti millennial male it must be a sad
thing to be Davey Pakman and have to
wake up every morning look in the mirror
and realize that you are an absolute
nutless so can we pause that on the
screen somehow because I want to look at
this
there is one accurate claim made okay it
says I'm an idiot that's a matter of
opinion it says I am a Democrat I have
never been a Democrat it says I'm HIV
positive I am not HIV positive it says
that I have a low IQ I don't believe
that to be true it says I have low
testosterone which medically speaking I
believe is not accurate but it says I am
Eleni Ulm a land that is true I am both
male and I am squarely in the Millennial
umbrella you're really on this thing
ever since I accused you of being part
of the Gen X generation you just can't
get off this topic okay so that aside
what is this testosterone problem
they're referring to I always find it
weird when people make fun of medical
problems like if you if you don't have
testicles because you've had a medical
issue or you've had a testicle removed
you would have a low testosterone issue
what why would that be something to use
as an insult right it means a medical
condition or you don't even have to have
a testicle removed I mean you could just
have low T levels don't have to have
injections I always find it odd when
people think it's funny to make fun of
medical problems anyway you can turn
hatred mail into something positive we
have a coupon code hatred for tha TR IOT
4-0 which at david pakman.com slash
membership will save you 40% off of
membership if that made you chuckle
consider getting a discounted membership
it's a really good way to sort of say if
you I guess to the hatreds or coffee or
Cubs Fe to the hatred